J'ai adoré vous faire une vidéo sur les papas
alors je ne pouvais pas ne pas vous faire une vidéo sur les mamans
Évidemment, chacun a sa propre définition d'une maman
Par exemple, selon moi, une maman c'est...
Cette personne qui met un sandwich dans ton sac,
sans que tu t'en rendes compte ;
Celle qui te fait porter de très très beaux pulls...
selon elle ;
Celle qui veut absolument  que tu t'habilles très chaudement,
même s'il fait déjà très chaud ;
Celle qui essuie un truc sur ton visage,
mais avec sa salive ;
Celle qui est très fière de toi pour des choses dont toi tu es pas très fier ;
Celle qui fait secrètement une collection de tupperwares ;
Celle qui sait mieux que toi où sont rangées tes propres affaires ;
Celle qui écrit ton nom et prénom partout sur tes affaires ;
Celle dont t'as besoin, dans les moments où tu sais pas comment faire ;
Celle qui même au bout du monde,
t'enverra un message pour te dire :
"J'espère que t'as fini tous tes légumes, hein ?"
SMS qu'elle aura écrit uniquement avec l'index ;
Celle qui est tellement dans ton esprit
qu'en cours t'as déjà dit « Maman! Euh! Madame »
*rires* « Pff j'voulais dire Madame »
C'est pas grave, Norman.
En tout cas toutes ces mamans, on en a besoin.
Mais parfois c'est l'inverse, c'est elles qui ont besoin de nous.
Et c'est souvent pour les mêmes choses.
Matéo ! On met comment l'application Internet ?
Est-ce que tu peux me brancher l'imprimante ?
J'aimerai imprimer Google Map.
Mathéo, débranche la box. Là, j'ai mal à la tête à cause du Wi-Fi
J'ai perdu mon carnet où j'écris les numéros des gens, là. Tu peux m'aider ?
Comment on envoie un sexto ?
Bon Matéo, enlève-moi internet, là ! J'ai besoin de téléphoner.
Matéo, tu peux me donner un conseil pour le...
- Bon, écoute ce que je vais faire, c'est que je vais directement t'amener un conseiller technique
qui va répondre à toutes tes questions.
Bonjour Madame. Quel est votre problème ?
Alors j'ai reçu un message "Jacquie et Michel"...
Les mamans elles sont souvent aussi de très bonnes comédiennes.
Comme par exemple quand il s'agit de faire semblant d'être contente.
Oh ! Tu m'offres un collier de nouilles ?
Oh oh merci mon chéri c'est trop mignon !
Bah écoute, moi cette année j'ai voulu être aussi généreuse que toi alors,
je t'offre un Ipad.
Un Ipad en nouilles.
Voilà, y'a pas de chargeur, hein. Ça marche direct.
Les Mamans, elles ont du pouvoir sur toi.
Elles savent comment te mettre la pression avec des phrases du genre :
Tu descends manger maintenant !
Je compte jusqu'à 3 !
1...
D'ailleurs, quand t'as toujours rien fait à 2, elles mettent une petite rallonge.
2 et demi. Preprepreprepresque 3
3 !! Nicolas !!
Les mamans, elles ont toujours envie de s’immiscer dans ta vie sentimentale, de manière gênante,
et te donner des conseils sur tes relations intimes.
Tu sais Chloé, si tu rencontre bientôt un petit copain,
tu pourras demander à maman des petits conseils techniques, hein? Si tu veux.
Dans les moindres détails. Y'a pas de soucis.
Maman ! Ça va, j'ai pas besoin de conseils, merci.
Oh, le gros bébé à sa maman qui va pas grandir
Moi quand j'étais petit, je pensais que les parents ils faisaient l'amour qu'une seule fois dans leur vie
pour avoir un enfant. Et puis j'ai grandi.
Et je me suis rendu compte que c'était plutôt absurde.
C'est vrai qu'avec papa, dès que vous faites l'amour, vous avez un enfant ?
Bah oui, Norman.
Voilà pourquoi ton père et moi avons 9 600 enfants
Eh oui, on adore les enfants.
Ou on adore faire l'amour.
Comment on fait l'amour ?
Ferme ta gueule.
Après, il y a les mamans hyper protectrices.
Celles qui sont prêtes à tout
pour protéger leur enfant de la moindre image néfaste, selon elles, à leur éducation.
Chloé ! Je t'inderdis de regarder "Stranger Things".
Tu vas encore faire pleins de cauchemars.
Met plutôt les infos, hein ? C'est beaucoup plus constructif.
[En Syrie, images atroces de ces enfants qui se font décapiter sur les places publiques.]
[Le sang coule à flot, c'est vraiment...]
Ouais, non. Remet plutôt "Stranger Things" en fait. Regarde toute la saison.
Y'a des mamans qui t'aiment tellement qu'elles sont prêtent à te confectionner des trucs.
Alors, c'est hyper mignon. À part quand c'est Halloween, et que ta mère a fait ton costume.
Moi, j'me souviens de ce fameux Halloween de mes 11 ans...
Hey, mais t'es déguisé en quoi ? En sac poubelle !
Euh, non, c'est le costume de Zorro qu'a fabriqué ma mère.
Heureusement, l'année suivante, ma mère s'était bien rattrapée
en s'appliquant vraiment sur mon costume de Spiderman.
Hey, mais... t'es déguisé en sac poubelle rouge !
Les mamans, elles ont aussi le rôle de nous disputer quand on fait une connerie.
Hein, ça c'est quand même la base.
Mais heureusement, la manière de punir les enfants, elle a quand même pas mal changé
depuis l'ancienne époque.
Maman, tu fais quoi ?
Oh, rien. Je fais des petits nœuds au bout des lanières du martinet
pour que ça fasse plus mal quand je te frapperai avec pour te punir.
Ah ok. Nickel.
Bah moi, je vais aller faire un petit tour là-bas à... à la DASS.
Tiens ! Prend ça, fils de chien !
Ouais, ça marche bien.
Enzo ! Arrête tout de suite, sinon j'te...
Je te fais rien du tout. Je te dispute verbalement
C'est pas bien d'égorger sa sœur.
Moi, y'a un truc qui me faisait toujours flipper quand j'étais petit,
c'était quand ma mère m'appelait, non pas par mon diminutif,
mais par mon nom complet.
C'est pas mal.
Norman Jacky Cyril Thavaud !!
Content de t'avoir connu, mec.
Oui, mère ?
Oui, mon deuxième prénom, c'est Jacky. On va pas en faire une histoire.
C'est vrai que quand j'y pense, à une place près, ça aurait pu être mon premier prénom.
Ma vie aurait été un peu différente.
♫ Jacky ! Jacky ! Ta 4L ... ♫
Bon, on va pas trop se moquer non plus du prénom Jacky,
puisque c'est également le prénom de mon père.
Quand t'es ado, y'a toujours un moment où tu te rebelles contre ta mère.
Et à ce moment-là, t'as envie de prouver au monde entier que t'as plus besoin d'elle.
T'façon, tu me comprendras jamais. T'es plus ma mère, ok ? Je fugue !!
En fait, j'ai réfléchi, et je t'aime trop.
Ah, t'étais parti ? Allez, va mettre la table, s'il-te-plaît.
Malheureusement, tout le monde n'a pas une famille modèle,
avec un papa et une maman qui s'aiment.
Maintenant, y'a plein de familles recomposées
Et c'est vrai que l'un des moments les plus délicats, sans doute,
c'est quand une maman annonce à ses enfants qu'elle fréquente un nouvel homme.
Tu vois Timothée, depuis que maman est plus avec papa, eh bien... maman voit d'autres hommes.
Voilà pourquoi j'te présente Laurent.
Et Bruno.
Salut.
Et Fabrice.
Enchanté...
Timothée ?
Pour conclure cette vidéo, j'aimerai vous dire un truc tout simple.
Tellement simple qu'on oublie parfois que c'est ce qu'il y a de plus important.
Mais dans la vie, ce qu'on a de plus cher, ça se trouve pas dans les bouquins,
sur le net ou à l'autre bout du monde.
Non, ce qu'on a de plus cher ça se trouve juste là, à côté de nous.
Notre famille, nos proches...
Et parfois, on les voit même pas.
Ou on se dit qu'on a toute la vie pour leur dire "je t'aime", mais ça c'est faux.
Alors si vous avez la chance d'avoir votre maman à vos côtés,
simplement, profitez-en chaque jour.
Chaque minute, chaque seconde.
Et prouvez-lui tout votre amour, parce que... vous en avez qu'une, quoi.
Voilà.